ça après deux ans d'absence julien clerc
revient sur scène à paris il est pour sa
semaine au palais des congrès avec entre
autres une très belle chanson inspirée
par la peine de mort l'assassin se
signer un reportage de gérard holtz qui
commence justement par julien clerc
interprétant cette chanson chacun son
rôle
ça m'aide pas trop
on lui donne 2 3 ap avoir fait un écrin
ne convient pas
bon la tâche pour le classe dans la cour
grotesque à van der garde et puis
ensuite par a très vite le temps que
l'on vous eu des capi
comment combattre en main
sans fond
foot
de vous chanter ah sinon
ces fonds
pour des bovins
lorsque le couteau est tombé
le a changé de côté
ce temps dans ma mémoire
en paraphant
ce matin
là
un battant
à
julien clerc la sas assassiné finalement
vous êtes décidé à chanter cette chanson
un petit peu à cause du journal
d'antenne 2 oui parce que j'étais envoyé
spécial du journal un procès qui est
tout à fait exemplaire je trouve en ce
qui concerne la peine de mort c'est à
dire enfin quelqu'un de pas très
sympathique qui est un récidiviste ses
attentes distance mais chose quand même
assez troublant et il s'est trouvé que
cette chose que dabadie avait écrite
depuis deux ans sur laquelle j'ai fait
musique tout de suite et que je
n'arrivais pas chanter je sais pas
pourquoi parce qu'on n'était pas sûr de
moi sans doute après avoir vu ce process
a vraiment été une illumination et j'ai
vraiment décidé de la mettre sur scène
je vais employer un petit raccourci
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes devenu
adulte comme ça d'un seul coup en
quelques mois là c'est un peu l'angoissé
au bout de douze ans que je chante
puisque ça fait ça j'en étais encore 20
ans j'en étais à 20 ans et depuis le
temps que je chante je crois que j'ai
jamais pris autant de plaisir à chanter
sur une scène pour ce faire je ne sais
plus qui a dit que l'art c'était le
plaisir moi je l'amène à la musique la
musique c'est le plaisir c'est le
plaisir pour soi même à prendre du
plaisir veulent quelque chose parce
qu'on en donne aux gens
non
m
à